our program begins now oh my god I'm
excited for this I was gonna try and get
you hyped but you're doing it yourself
we can do this though hi I'm Jesse Cox I
am a massive Larry and fan I am up here
gonna host this fun panel that we have
in store for you today I'm really
excited this is the gameplay reveal
panel for baldur's gate 3
[Applause]
we've got about 10 minutes of game
playing and about eight spreadsheets a
few pie charts and 45 minutes of QA
right pretty much and we know what you
love lots of spreadsheets numbers lots
of those anyway all right how many of
you by show of hands are big Larian fans
all right and how many of you were like
Baldur's Gate I love that and by show of
ice room two hands how many of you are
fans of both I got everyone to do the
wave I'm feeling really good about that
all right we are going to look I could
talk all day I I could but no one cares
what I think because all of you are here
to see this man Sven Fink is going to
play for you Baldur's Gate three and I'm
gonna shut up and let him do that
because this is going to be the coolest
thing you will ever see and I'm gonna
just hand it over to you
[Applause]
hold on wait a minute wait a minute I
fall so we can get louder than that this
is gonna be crazy
we had to turn people away there are
people still outside you even louder to
make them sadder louder get excited
Baldur's Gate three scream for this man
[Applause]
thank you I love you too so what you're
about to see is a game that's still in
development so it's literally pre-alpha
footage we're not going to show you a
video we're gonna just play I don't know
what's gonna happen
furthermore to make it even more
exciting the save game system is broken
so that means that if I die if it's the
party wipe I'll just have to restart so
we'll try not to have that happen if you
see a bug and available you will see
something it's something that we see -
we'll fix it
we still have a whole bunch of time
before it's gonna be ready I it was
announced that it's going to early
access we actually wanted to announce it
today but people were very excited about
announcing it for us so and it's gonna
be an early access in a couple of months
we don't know exactly when when it's
ready for early access and with that set
we're just going to start up I will
small intro and then start chatting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we have a problem it is so good to
meet you there is something I want to
give you
already different people gonna
understand great name so we're in
character creation I can select my
background so these are all the dungeon
dragons backgrounds that you know play
Dungeons and Dragons and I could play
change my body type
I can change my race so I can play as a
thief playing I can play as a drove it
plays a human basic it Yankee you can
play as a dwarf there's an elf if
there's a half elf
I can play as a half draw there's a
halfling and there's more but we're only
showing a few these are the races that
will be going into early access and
they're more will be added afterwards
and so depending on which race I think I
get different features I can also select
which boss I'm gonna play we have six
classes that would entail below an early
access from the get-go and then it will
just add as before we progress so I can
place the wizard cleric fighter Ranger
row and warlock and then I can pick the
abilities like ability points that go
with that and select my skills and which
I'm going to be proficient today we're
gonna play an origin story so we have
different origin stories and there's
gonna be five that are gonna be in early
access there will be more often so this
is my cell she's the girl you saw in the
intro so she is a Yankee Gayle is a
wizard he has a very big problem and
that's pretty much that he's going to
explode and shadowheart she's a dark
cleric as she's 40 story too
well as a monster hunter who made a pact
with the devil he regrets it
and today we're gonna play as a star in
who is a vampire spawn he's a noble so
vampire spawn is not really a vampire he
has a vampire vampire to which he is a
slave he's a high elf which means that
we get to select a cancer for him it is
going to pick mage ham because we're
gonna do cool things with it and all the
rest is already preset for him so we
just have to click the venture forth
button and we can continue
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so we're gonna skip the tutorial because
it's not ready yet
and so I will tell you what happens in
tutorial or at least in a nutshell we're
gonna capture that nota Lloyd we're
going to do that together with the get
Yankee warrior that you so captured in
the intro and we're going to teleport it
to a place called faerun more
specifically to the sword coast more
specifically 200 miles to the east of
Baldur's Gate that was by the way the
city that you saw the sword is not ball
scale it was your tar
daylight is comfy
what the hell's is coming so what I
forgot to mention is that my vampires
form normally come walk in the sunlight
he can't go over running water and he
needs an invitation if he wants to enter
somewhere but apparently he can walk in
the sunlight so that's kind of handy for
us so he's going to try to figure out
what's going on so I can't control the
camera and put it in third person so
then it's running behind me or I can
just go back top-down and then basically
play it in a traditional manner so I'm
going to like going like this and that's
fine
over there
[Music]
sunlight
so this is a reverse voltage I don't
turn it but not push money and it
reaches all the way to baldur's gate but
we have no boat so we're gonna have to
go in a different direction
no fun over here
sure
below that there's none of my business
it's magnificent
Darden doesn't really care about the
fact that everybody's dead she is
banging at door so listen to ask and
introduce ourselves
blast it doors like what huh it's you I
saw you on the ship you survived then
suddenly I saw what she saw felt what
she felt anger confusion results
you've got the same thing I do in your
head I felt it okay so I have a whole
bunch of dialogue options so what just
happened to us is because of the tadpole
I was already introduced to that in
tutorial we call it mind-melding so we
both have a tadpole in our heads and we
can telepathically connect to each other
but I'm also very hungry so I'm playing
this from point of view of a star in
vampire spawn and so you will see that
all of my choices will be tailored to
being a star and essentially so I'm
gonna stare at her and realize that I'm
very hungry
has that tadpole scrambled your brain
already so I can basically say okay well
I'll just feed or I can swallow my urge
and find ignorance which is what I'm
going to do because I needed a companion
the chase through hell the creatures
what they did to us the tadpole that
thing is going to consume us from the
inside and turn us into mind flares you
and I need a healer finding one won't be
easy in this wilderness we'll need
supplies I'm hoping something of use
might be behind these doors but I barely
made a dent in them so far okay so I can
offer to help her but I'm a rogue also
so I can tell her to save her strength
then that I will pick the lock by all
means
I'm going to see what's at the top of
this cliff
hopefully there's no more of these
creatures along the way I will well
actually I suggest that we joined forces
and say that that gives us better also
survival or just company for our final
moments but you're right whatever lies
ahead will be a little less daunting
with support you can call me shadowheart
I can tell her that I'm a star in a
reformed vampire spawn we can walk in
the sunlight or can choose not to tell
her which is a good idea and I can also
question her what she knows about the
things in each of our heads very little
supposedly those monsters breed by
planting their tadpoles in people's
heads over time the infected victim
turns into a mind flare I don't remember
how long it takes but we should hurry
that's a problem I'll introduce myself
Starion lead the way it's Talia and I've
made my first companion that's right so
what pick that door but I don't have a
lock pick
oops and I got myself into the door
alright and let's see this fine
gentleman has something of use but he
doesn't
[Music]
that's usually an introduction to combat
when you see something like that let's
try and see what it is
and this is so combat is turn-based it
goes tension and drags a turn-based
system so okay so cellphone that I need
to be very careful for these intellect
divorce because if they get too close to
me it will be very painful this can
actually end up in the party wives
without goodbye very bad right I'm gonna
stick the high ground and dungeon
dragons seeking advance which allows you
to roll twice which is a good idea
because a lot of dice rolling going on
behind the scenes as you'll soon see we
translate the dice rolls into
percentages so that you don't have to do
all the mathematics yourself so just
give me a 90% chance to hit so that's a
pretty good one also
I'll manage don't worry about it that's
a 45 percent that's not so good let's
try i'm calling second puny to damage so
if you're curious to know how the
calculations are going happening they're
happening behind the scenes here you can
just hover over it and then you can
learn all of the math behind the numbers
that you see which is why Jessie said
lots of numbers we're gonna be very
brief and we're just gonna go up there
and then I'm gonna see how far I can get
this Darian because I don't want him to
die right away
alright shadowheart really me just my
recruiter the boom is action these are
my actions these are my bONIES action so
you just see yeah it says ap it's a
little bit misleading yeah but it's
actually just the actions that you have
but sometimes you can have two of them
so I'm going to end my turn
I know it's the enemy's turn
unfortunately they can turn that's good
you can hit me that's actually enough
that that so what I'm gonna do with
shadowheart is I'm gonna try something
that's a little bit risky but sometimes
worse I'm going to use the shop and I'm
going to try to
so that guy's a little bit further for
me and then she can still hammer at that
guy really not hitting very well and
then I'm gonna shoot with a star and
that guy we're doing pretty good
actually
so common is fairly high stakes as you
can see so they have reactions that
basically means if she walks away from
here they're gonna hit her which is not
good so what I'm gonna do and he and he
comes so I have a jump I didn't want to
use it yet but for something to man
some peasant boys action
that means that I can't use another film
is actually access it disengage also and
it's in the house by my desk all that I
have in inside of me I do have one
action that I can still do so I'm just
gonna try it out this is my mage hands
my match hand is bad that's many things
but it's very good at throwing stuff so
I'm gonna
[Applause]
I wanted to show this to you today but
you have no idea how nervous I was about
doing it because I was going to get in
this situation so I obviously should
have approached them in completely
different manner we'll see the next
combat how you can actually be much more
strategic planning famous first I guess
all right she is hurting so she's gonna
drink my first giving potion I don't
have a lot of them then she's just gonna
actually
all right well no all right here comes
that's good oh no no no getting back up
very high stakes he's fighting for the
shots that's interesting okay mage hands
where are you do your thing
to 80% so sorry yeah you can also throw
bodies that you find in the world but
it's not working
so that's why I'm using the shot
actually and it's working but it doesn't
exist
oh why did I go to sneak i misclicked
really did I put my hand in to sneak
that's really clever
so other day the announcement was that
it was going to be life I think so
alright
90% shot that should oh yeah actually I
have a pin down attack which is a action
that you get with your weapon so each
point that you get gives you an extra
type of action yes your I know that
you're sneaking you got this you got
this I have a plan
I got a boat a little bit greased so I'm
just gonna - can you stop hands and I
normally is not supposed to be able to
hit like this actually can you don't you
do anything useful if they want to
attack you maybe
okay all right so either dip your hands
yeah hand is not supposed to die but
well swimmingly okay so I wanted to
throw so I have a true action I can
throw pretty much everything in a
presentation I did previously had threw
my boots so for comedic effect I'll just
throw my boots maybe I'll actually it's
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
not actually
so where is she does one of those
anymore
that's so she's down she's not dead yet
so that's the good news
so basically how this works is this is
def saving TRO so each turn there's
gonna be a role behind the scenes and if
it's a good role and then we're gonna
get a little blue spot like this and if
you have three of them she gets
stabilized and if we get three red ones
because it's a bad role then she dies
and there are going to keep on hitting
at her because if she goes to the
negative over maximum HP she dies too so
we're gonna try to avoid that from
happening but I'm really not I shouldn't
have thrown to do this by the way that
was really stupid move this looks like a
really good kid that's excellent and we
have one guy left thank you
why huh okay well let's hope that this
one's gonna go right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay well I I did tell you that oh hold
on this is work
alright so so I do have the same problem
is real so it is genuine so I need to
restart so I'm just gonna do a quick
restart I'll just do it as fast and I
will just we'll do Q&A for five minutes
you got it out of the way early yeah
that's why they gave us and a half hour
extra day absolutely you're fine
I'll just sneak past the fight and we'll
go to the next one let's otherwise might
be in trouble
luckily for you my trust image and major
form go forward into the game and I will
recruit shadowheart again so I'll do
that in the shortest possible manner and
then I suggest we try to avoid the
intellect divorce take a different route
if we can and if we can't well we'll
have to fight them again before we
proceed with our adventure so yeah I've
done this like we've done press tour in
the last three weeks and I've done this
like 30 40 times I in general do not die
on it although it's over
meanwhile we can also look at a few
other speakers on the game make them
walk over there starting to run run the
story and run run run run over here
thank you
so meantime we can have a look at the
back side of the UI so this is where you
see all my equipment here you see all of
my abilities and so when you click on
the sky your skills distances and this
is my spell book where the spells that I
know
blasted doors like what oh it's you
I saw you on the ship you survived then
suddenly I saw what she saw felt what
she felt anger confusion you you've got
the same thing I do in your head
I felt it okay so I'm just gonna be very
nice and the creatures what they did to
us the tadpole that thing is going to
consume us from the inside and turn us
into mind flares you and I need a healer
finding one won't be easy in this
wilderness we'll need supplies I'm
hoping something of use might be behind
these doors but I barely made a dent in
them so far I'm gonna help you my guest
but that doors too strong maybe there's
another way
look the cliff hopefully there's no more
of these things
or just company for our final minister
but you're right whatever lies ahead
will be a little less daunting with
support you can call me shadowheart yep
I'm a star meet the way it started do
you want to take an audience vote on if
we do this fight again
switch sides okay so now I'm doing I'm
gonna play it like a pro
it's really well and I saw her do other
things first of all I am gonna dip my
beau into the fire
there we go then I'm gonna press this
button which allows me to enter
turn-based mode outside of combat and so
in that way you can sneak up on people
and you can do all kinds of things that
they don't expect you to do and then
basically the way that that works is
that they have six seconds oh yeah these
are oh man if I can make the enemies
turn so they get to patrol for six
seconds they're not doing anything
that's good you see that over there
that's explosive so I'm gonna try to get
there
shoot
[Applause]
each other heart is still waiting for me
I'll make her join film that much better
I feel much more relaxed about this
fight
I'm gonna pin him down there you go this
is how it's supposed to be and then I
did actually have a very strong attack
but I never got to use it which is
guiding balls and put them to use now
where's the other guy but put her in
front of it - Thomas you
[Music]
you can't move anymore that's good the
other guy very enthusiastically coming
towards us she's gonna use for guiding
voltage and generally to kill them in
one shot
there you go damage and then we're going
to shoot
[Applause]
alright that was exciting
see what this guy he's got a silver
locket and dagger I don't need to do
that I've got one already with the
rapier I might want to use so go and go
for it and explore a little bit more the
world has to offer us
so like in all of our games you can move
two things in the environment but we've
got we've added a whole bunch of stuff
that you can do so we can print and make
a stair why would you make us tear
it's fine you're doing great it's fine
well
I think ok so here's another example of
why you would want to do a turn-based
mode
say that you want to kill this war or
talk to it or whatever you can now just
press the button and then you can just
plan your move goes to it and then it
has six seconds so I press my spacebar
now it will move for six seconds then
it's my turn
well it will use this to surprise people
and sneak up on them and hopefully do it
really well just gonna try to jump over
although I think actually
but usually I star in the dice this is
an example of a passive check so my
nature skill was used to discover
something so if it would have failed
that would know founded of course I
found the old gas the gas belongs to the
Harper's so give me a little secret but
it's specially this thing that I need
the support of speech if you double my
points and it's going to also allow me
to get to actions which is really good
we're gonna try it very complicated
stunts probably succeed or fail see what
I did there
probably succeed or fail
this seems as good a place as any to
make camp and rest might as well adapt
the daywalkers ways so your camp is a
place that's going to expand over time
you will be able to get followers in
your camp your companions will obviously
be here also and so there's a lot of
relationship building happening in your
camp I'm not sure this is a good idea I
can tell her not to question me or
however I'm gonna try to befriend her
some ask her what she needs
there are lit fuses in our heads sooner
or later they're going to blow each hour
that passes the thing inside us gross we
need to find a healer let's wake up at
first light okay so I'm going to agree
with her and because finding help is
indeed our very first concern maybe
we'll get lucky we're overdue some good
fortune rest well
well lead our strength I tried to rest
but my mind wouldn't settle just
yesterday I had been seducing a young
nun luring him to my Master's lair since
then I've been kidnapped by mind flayers
chased through hell by dragons and
fallen from the sky and I felt the Sun
on my skin I should have burst into
flames
so I can ask myself questions will be
the moment of introspection I can think
of my master it will be furious I could
be a vampire spawn yeah actually it's a
good question kind of a vampire's bone
even becoming my player the worm in my
head might not even have an appetite for
undead meat until I knew more about the
tableau I wasn't sure how much danger I
was in I had to understand it master it
I needed to find someone who knew more
about this thing so I'm going to try to
get some sleep and I'm gonna imagine
dragging my old master into the sunlight
and that's the persuasion against myself
so I need to roll I need to do it in
thousands check basically so the way
that works is actually there's a
built-in modifiers on it and we just
show you the actual vici that comes out
at the end mmm I drifted off with a
smile meditating on the flames that
engulfed his cruel face you gonna be
happy in mourning okay
thank you so all of the dialogues in the
game like literally all of them have
been performance captured force they
recorded given cinematic treatment and
there hasn't been any compromise because
the whole cinematic that we're doing in
there so there's plenty of permutations
and you need to realize that I'm now
playing with a star in so it wouldn't be
playing with a star and we would have
different things happening to us
and you'll see that we've gone very far
in this thing's over there worth
checking for supplies maybe
[Music]
live that's unexpected last I saw you
you were lying in a crucibles worth of
blood an intellect devour and nibbling
in your air glad to see my eyes deceive
me and Gayle well met
so my vampire eruption is that I sent
something off I was certainly good
tastes like vile I can obviously draw my
weapon because I don't trust a guy
speechless might be the shock we went
through a traumatizing experience if I'd
instructive one if I throw my he refers
to the thing they put in my eye yes
the ocular penetration bar on a lifted
tadpole which will end with our souls
being snuffed like strands of we've
caught in dead magic not to mention
you're staring at me like a Roisin me on
a blackboard
no no wizard are you I can obviously
just decide to feed but I will tell him
that I don't take kindly to insults
thin-skinned and a daughter of questions
usually means the answer's no guess
that'll have to wait
primary need now is a healer I take it
you recall the insertion of the parasite
not only do they recall it and I said I
was already enjoying its effects
referring to the fact that I can walk in
Sun
interesting are you aware that after a
period of excruciating gestation it'll
turn us into mind flayers process known
as Sarah morphosis it is to be avoided I
assume you'll know accomplished healer
either powerful cleric maybe okay what's
this a conversation or an interrogation
just trying to figure out where we stand
conclusion nowhere you and I are in a
whole lot of trouble
we need help I'm not sure where we'll
find it in this wilderness how about we
embark on the quest for a healer
together yes excellent then without
further ado let's be off besides looks
like you keep some interesting company a
woman with shadows for eyes deep as the
dark lake pleasure madam is it indeed
we'll see
she's gonna do a few things for I
actually had to kill them so I'm gonna
separate him from my party and as I know
what's coming so I want to show you
something and I'm gonna go with them
well actually I'm first gonna position
him because these guys this can turn out
that the other combat
and so the way sneaking works and the
ball circuitry is that if you see a
shadow it's gonna lightly obscure you
all right if you walk into the sunlight
you are going to be in the clear area so
when you're in a clear area and you get
seen a you are caught on sight if you go
into a obscured area then you have to
roll stealth 20 and if you get caught
get caught which might actually succeed
if you are heavily obscured as you will
soon see you can actually just walk
right off it's kind of cool because
every single shadow suddenly has use but
there's also meter you can multiply
shadows you can light or move light is
here standing on this creative process
if he does I'm just gonna leave him here
and then over here and demonstrates a
small thing that I just discovered this
morning because normally what I do here
go first of all that show that you still
have all kinds of environmental
interactions that you can use everything
that makes sense within the world of
Dungeons & Dragons we've you can
vaporize wall to which fire but there's
also other good things that you so
normally I just show this and I say okay
well this is where we are we start from
here basically I do it to show that you
can navigate over very high in portable
world but I figured that if I cast
feather fall then I make a jump
so she's a nice fellow item if she would
have jumped without feather for maybe we
can do that too
you'll die anyway no he has to walk back
[Music]
feather falls are very useful spell the
game has an enormous amount of
verticality will never get the places
where the verticality is applying today
because we don't have enough time and we
introduce it to gradually two players
but you will be surprised by how much
stuff you can do we can walk on roofs
you can jump all the way down into very
very very deep holes just going to get
the feather pole wrong with feather
falls it takes up a sir if you if you
use it all right that's a good thing I
was supposed to do so in let's regroup
them there's a small problem with the
interface here so you know though we see
their group but they should be good
hopefully
so let's go meet these fine gentlemen
and say hello to them you pal twice as
tall as me but I'm off that bloody
backbone but we don't know what that
thing even is and what about the Crypt
I'm telling you it's a ship and the
Crypt can wait
mari and barton have been trying to
break in for days now we stopped got
ourselves competition already that's our
ship okay so we have a bunch of
persuasion options I can tell them that
I was just looking around
tell them that the ship was full of
monsters my many comrades were coming
but I can try to intimidate them you're
gonna tell there's plenty of monsters
and then I mean you'll roll hard yeah
think you can get us to leave that
bounty to you not a chance
what are you not waiting for dinner
[Music]
luckily for me I planned for this and so
if you do a shot out of a sleep Edition
that is a whole new set chance
[Music]
okay so that was my action for this one
this trying to do this really well I'm
going to use Greece Greece is gonna
trade difficult ranges and difficult
terrain is basically going to half their
movements beaten as they're trying to go
over it so that's good I also we made
Greece flammable so if I can Maya
put fire on it it's gonna hurt them
double and of course we have no source
of fire anymore because I used up my
fire
so let's see
well somebody's gonna have to stand
there
okay that's a witch ball so she can
every turn as long as is concentrated
this is gonna be able to hurt me do I
need to do something about that this
guy's trying to go up to get to this
office back
I'm gonna have to I'm gonna have to use
the cheat here no oh oh okay oh yeah no
I just worked I actually destroyed his
father since secretly with a secret
secret but she'll remain secret well
Mitch over his office first okay well
let's just do it the seat where did he
get
look at that you can actually jump on
them also and that person do so with a
warrior with feather pull Victorians
combined up the men jump on somebody and
converge however this was actually
really nice it was just a throw I can
still shoot I need to make this hits
because otherwise shadow art is gonna be
in trouble
it'll be a pin down 75% shows
so that means that she is now
I'm sorry there it's like I was a little
bit too in suggesting something it went
away
good actually changes things
[Music]
don't forget
all right so how far are you
I'm hitting it
so far for money I don't have any
quietly
she can - gonna make her -
very Harvard getting a bit partners that
canceled the entire effect but maybe I
yell at them I don't yell I don't have a
yellow yet we will have
they need us again
I'm gonna die here
I got a thing you don't want to restart
again
then again
yes thank you
that's why you guys are here hard-headed
we have magic pockets we have magic
pockets
you're basically telling me to run away
right
oh I'll have enough having excellent
idea this is going to work really well
so let me first write
did I throw something already back and
still do I can't remember
good work
partes well as for see which direction
they're gonna go actually because I can
go back they can get moves to her give
her a helping hand
again
all right we're gonna make
somebody said five or six ounce
I'll do it again
I'm throw Decker makes a bit more sense
yeah before I mean actually those things
help
[Music]
we'll get there it might be hard to work
though Oh actually with what I can still
do no I get the sweet again this right
all right
it happens that you miss a lot anyway
today I think looks at everything that
it pops
[Applause]
alright so out of combat they're deaf
stepping through or she's really dead
she's dead
we'll worry about our later believer
there
she deserves it well let's first see
what they had to pick up
don't reach standing next to her
actually let's give this to you
fancy stuff make them look more like the
real wizards
he's a rope a beard now
worth mentioning a board that BK you can
play the game in love the barrel sir
there can be no flourishing stories I
have to mention it you can play us
everybody is a hero
so much of a personality they
multiplayer like with being able to
participate in each other startups in
what year other options other person is
considering something that can quite
intense as you'll see
so we're gonna go inside here like you
keep a book everything all right out
there I'm gonna claim to be gibble Baca
and ask him to let me you don't worry
we're safe if it fails bro do you sound
the be shaken boss hang on while I find
the key
[Music]
your jet no you're just and race why is
because I I surprise them and when you
surprise somebody you get English
so this guy has absolutely no chance the
first thing I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go
over here I'm going to shoot there you
go and then I'm gonna shoot him again
then I know he's gonna try to run away
and force his buddies just fine shoot
him again
and that's how easy it can be all right
let's see where we end up I'm sorry in
the great Tomb Raider it's gonna do all
this on his own just as a demonstration
of how systemic use is again just
okay so I'm gonna switch the lights off
I'm gonna go sneak box and I'm going to
put myself into four stern basements and
I'm gonna try to sneak up behind this
one so I can she's probably gonna start
turning back so I'm gonna go and stand
the corner here I'm heavily obscured I
don't come too close they're not gonna
detect me all right I'm just gonna stand
there now there she is this is a reason
why so you have a little hole here why
because this slides is creating assuming
that she can see in and then assume just
in front of her but here that we're
standing here I would have been actually
okay
[Music]
this is my sneak attack so if I do it
formally I get 1d6
extra damage was
why aren't you
[Music]
I'm gonna bite through yes I'm gonna
keep my bite for later
okay so I'm gonna go over here
yes it's safe
to take my dipping action torch my sword
my boat I think my arrows actually what
suggested and somebody put a [ __ ]
barrel here for me this is cool sticking
out over this crates darkness
let's try to do that again
so the trick here is that I'm gonna try
to get into this place
[Music]
so we're gonna create a zone of darkness
and so the zone of darkness is basically
going to cover me so that he can't see
me while I'm in there
wait
Ozona
I was actually quite
[Music]
[Music]
the light of course we're still working
on better visualization of this but
starting the great doom grader has
managed something because being detected
all right let's continue
so our doors open
[Applause]
I like it music changes when you start
music system is super adaptive alright
this has a tendency of going wrong I'll
do my outro best this is a thank you a
dangerous mix here is skeletons lying on
the floor and there's things that are
popping up and I have perception checks
that are succeeding that are failing so
you know that something's gonna happen
and then there's this big thing in the
middle inside they have grease appearing
everywhere fire appearing so but I knew
exactly where to stand and I'm gonna go
because turn-based move is also
something that you can use to navigate
traps so you got six seconds to think
and then the traps that get their turn
and you get your turn so you get the
gist so the way that I figured out is
getting out of here
mhm hands can throw stuff and so what I
can do so that I can make my own stairs
so I can make a stair out of here
and then back to mage hands I got a do
it the way that the way that I'm doing
it because I practiced this and when I
did its wrongly I drew it too far the
creative damage and then I jumped on top
of it and then the credit destroy it and
then I died anyway so
so having turn-based mode allows us to
do much cooler traps and not having you
to require to have lightning-fast
reflexes in one of the game which has
many many spells many many actions that
you can do so it's kind of the problem
if you want to talk to very fast
creatures
okay little jump now
there's no space there is enough space
man why do you have to follow me chance
[Music]
all right well that's that's handy hm
receptions like we're successful because
I'm supposed to have a perception check
but you have to do it that's cool
because then I can actually throw this
thing on that that way there's no more
grease coming out of it I use my job you
think I can make it
you have to stop
all right this is a bit harder than I
expected it to be
that's gonna take that grease away and
that's just see what I'm gonna get out
of it
my greatest broken
man I'll bet I made a corridor here so
that's good so now we know that don't
just have my - I guess I can walk over
there and stand in Greece for a second
you over there yep make that jump just
have to get there
I'm not jinx it
don't fall okay we made it outside of
the very evil trap
[Music]
so we're gonna get to the final room of
this mini dungeon so this is kind of
situation you'll find yourself in if
you're in multiplayer and you're just
dashing off and leaving your party
behind you can always manage it's just
sometimes a little bit tricky so many do
no signs of a stroke so we're entering a
big room and so you see a bunch of
skeletons on the floor so you are all
gamers you know what's gonna happen
these guys are gonna race so here's a
little trick I figured out yes I can
take their weapons away
unfortunately because disarming somebody
is actually an invalid action the AI
developers are making it so that they
will pick up the websites that they if
they see something on the floor and they
are unharmed the AI will actually come
to the same car at the conclusion on its
own but luckily it's not implemented yet
we can take advantage of this today
you're gonna give this guy's sort just
so that we can see the difference
between the guys have all of them I just
want to make sure that the guys with the
bow
you have a book now there's not a
marksman over there yet I'm gonna try
the final heist this little tomb raiding
adventure and if I fail they'll spot me
me I'll then consider whether or not I'm
gonna resurrect them failed
I need Yale so but Yale has a shortcut
there was actually a I can also bring a
star in Boots so there's an actual
shortcut but I didn't want to do it
because when you do it it alerts the
guards on the inside and they all gang
up and then I can't do a starring on his
own
if you shoot this thing and somebody
standing under it he'll die but it also
creates a
and then we find ourselves into this
room here and then like this I can open
this room so that was a shortcut but
then they basically all the banners that
are in this dungeon then stand outside
of this door and they're ready to kill
you
where is it
so here would have a better chance of
doing a succeeding in a history check
which I think no it's a perception
actually let's just try it up maybe
we'll we won't open it today so it's
another secret the game is full of
secrets exploration is heavily rewarded
you will never see all the secrets in
the one go it's impossible I'm gonna
send you over here this is the exit so
this is where in a second the start and
we'll have to manage just in case
okay so the reason why we came here is
because we want it we have poisons
that's fine because we can throw poison
people with all that skeletons of course
but this amount of joy and sorrow which
gives me to speak with that spell
so speaking with that is something
ready to have a modern
something just won't come unfortunately
I don't have myself I just realized that
this is the reason I keep my speed
potion in general
why are you standing here anyway let's
just hug the wall
the way it's for them to move
okay this should be easy at this point
[Music]
this is also why we need some better
indications so that we're working on
because this looks bright because the
artistic with the light here but for the
game it's actually it's a heavily
obscured soon things that were still
need to fix but the ocean of speed I was
already out of here somebody made me
drink it
well I'm heavily obscured they actually
have dark vision so they actually it
should have been a check so I think that
they the dark vision does work but it's
fine it's good I mean like look rooms
are the exit and they have no arrows to
have no bows they have no weapons okay
they all have their hands like exactly
how it should be the AI is trying to
figure out what the hell am I gonna do
right I'm gonna dash
okay
don't do anything
all right and then that's my movement
bar by the way the amount of moving they
have Gayle joins the thing the action
oh I only have five minutes left [ __ ] Oh
oh yeah I was my phone is charging I
forgot my timer so all right well let me
I I wanted to show you one last thing
he gave up the beep is like I'm done
[Laughter]
I'm thinking that if I manage to click
it in here oh let me to let me do this
oh it's the hands
Oh
no-no-no
well okay well since I only have five
minutes that will be the end of my
presentation
[Applause]
we have time for a few questions Jessie
do we yeah I mean there's already a
guide lining up go for it yeah all right
I've never played baldur's gate before
and based on what I've seen so far I
really really really want you now
however my luck is abysmal what advice
do you have for for someone with awful
luck other than you are asking him other
than playing on easy yeah so there's
ways that you can modify your dice you
seek out advantage which allows you to
roll twice so that's something that's
important we will have an easier mode we
still have to balance stuff also so the
values that you're seeing right now
we're pretty much straight out of the
book so sometimes it's fairly harsh but
we'll make sure that when it gets to you
this is one of the reasons we're going
to early access it will be manageable
because as you can see it's very brutal
sometimes thank you can't wait to play
in it thank you hi so quick question is
it possible to restart your companions
say that again
can you restate your companions so yes
you will be able to modify your
companions ability points and their
class
[Music]
yeah I called answer that question yet
okay thank you so the reason why I
couldn't answer your questions because
it's a point of discussion right now for
spell slots do they recharge after a
long rest or after long rest long rest
yeah so you need to go back to camp
actually the next thing do we're gonna
do was resurrect them and go to camp and
have a camp moment so that we would
respect and then we actually had a big
finale but we never go there sorry about
making you use that potion I know you
said this is early access and everything
but there's one interaction that
happened that I have to ask about you
didn't just tell anyone you were a
vampire and you walk up in a camp oh I'm
gonna do like the daywalkers do look at
their companion I didn't mean that
was that a a bug in the system where
she's supposed to react or and yeah yeah
there was a there was a small moment of
a note that it froze there he didn't get
anything okay thank you hi I wanted to
ask what consoles is this game me to be
coming on I know it's coming out on like
stadia I think PC and stadium so
understanding that this game is a pretty
much removed from the previous two
baldur's gate games is there a chance
that we might see characters from our
previous adventures such as a particular
Ranger with a hamster companion
we're only talking about the five
companions that we're showing today
unfortunately so I can't answer that
question just curious the part where you
attacked the ear companion I noticed
that was sort of a real-time combat are
we going is it going to be strictly
turn-based like we saw or everything is
happening in turn-based so that was
actually she didn't react to it she
should have reacted but her reaction
system isn't ready yet so she should
have reacted to the fact that I stabbed
her so but no combat is turn-based
dungeon dragons turn-based and we wanted
to do a port that was as faithful as we
could but still makes for a good video
game and by doing it this way we can
actually pretty much do one-on-one
mapping of a lot of of systems and that
works quite well
some big fan of Boas gate I had a
question is there gonna be like an
alignment system is it gonna impact with
kind of how the storyline plays out so
alignment is less pronounced and it used
to be and so and when we started out
working on it we actually also had in
our heads we're gonna make alignment a
really big thing but then Wizards
actually asked us a little bit to tone
it down because they didn't want it to
make it that that black and white
anymore and however you are going to
depending on your actions you have good
character scale is a good character for
instance it's not going to stay very
long with you if you're going to keep on
doing very very very crazy evil things
and it's a real pity that we didn't get
to the end of my presentation because I
was going to do the ultimate evil thing
I was gonna bite one of my companions at
night
but it failed but there will be a lot of
press up and you will be able to see it
in the stuff that they have had to talk
about and I was going to let you decide
whether or not we're going to do the
bite and then whether or not we're going
to completely drain my companion or
leave a little bit of blood and all that
and kind of yes of course I mean but you
it's your choice right you roll with
your choices and then then there's a d20
that you have to roll to makes you to
see if she actually detects it or not I
wish is kind of cool kind of follow-up
to that will your actions affect your
alignment like if you start off good and
make a bunch of evil choices so whether
your alignment is going to change so we
actually don't show alignments right now
in the game so there is no modification
of alignment for the moment I spend my
man choose the 93 Club Brugge Nell Smith
is one of the senior writers on ballers
gate 3 he's a Manchester United fan
I'm from Bruges is in Belgium and our
teams were playing now as the
presentation started and so we just felt
this was necessary hey they're huge fan
of you guys had a quick question
regarding early access could you talk a
little bit more about that like rough
estimate for a release date how much of
the campaign is gonna be ready anything
like that
wait there's somebody waving with the
time does that mean I have to shut up so
to answer your question so we're gonna
roll it into early access when bugs like
what you saw are all gone we're very
curious to get the community feedback so
that's the thing that's very important
for us I will make sure there's enough
content in there to keep you busy we
will make sure that you don't have all
the content so that when the release
comes you'll get plenty of content to
play through pretty much like we did
with our previous games but I can't give
you the exact figures on that just yet
all right I guess that's gonna be the
last question
[Applause]